j'accueille irina villeray
lima villeray bonsoir disparu le 28
janvier dernier jacques vivrait été l'un
des acteurs les plus touchants du cinéma
français on l'a vu en 1991 joue l
extraterrestre dans la soupe aux choux
en 86 l'été en pente douce en 88
le dîner de cons ce qui lui a valu un
césar sans oublier la scène avec la
contrebasse vous avez partagé son
quotidien pendant 25 ans et aujourd'hui
vous témoigner dans un livre publié chez
flammarion qui s'appelle un jour tout
ira bien
voilà alors votre père était producteur
de cinéma vous êtes né dans le milieu
voulais être actrice au départ fréquenté
un endroit qui s'appelait le sherwood où
il y avait huit ster balmer dussollier
et la première fois que oui jacques
villeret il est là il est il a un peu
saoul déjà oui c'est vrai qu'il y avait
une tendance à s'oublier un type et dans
l'est comme par l'alcool ensuite vous
resté cinq ans on le voir et vous leur
envoyez en 1978 fait que les sens si
vous invite à son one man show et après
le spectacle qui vous invite à dîner et
ils vous révèlent sa sa blessure en fait
c'est à dire son père algérien
oui c'est vrai il a vécu pendant des
années sous une autre identité et je
crois que ça a été une très grande
blessure évidemment et qu'il a suivi
toute sa vie puisque il a découvert une
façon difficile par le directeur de
l'établissement scolaire qui lui a rendu
ses papiers le livret de famille que il
ne portait pas du tout selon l'ars ce
soir là au fil des eaux file des verts
le personnage sa sombre et il finit par
vous dire qu'il n'est pas programmé pour
vivre jean déduisez quoi bah ça m'émeut
évidemment je rentre en jean très
immédiatement compassion or le lendemain
ils vous envoient des roses rouges
vous êtes séduit tu parles par l'acteur
évidemment mais vous n'êtes pas
tellement séduite par par l'homme mais
c'est pas ça c'est que en fait moi je
suis maman j'ai décidé de vivre seule
avec mon enfant
donc je ne suis pas prête à entrer en
amour avec qui que ce soit c'est
difficile quand on a un enfant
d'embarquer dans une histoire
on a le sentiment en lisant votre
bouquin qui s'accroche à vous
complètement à ce moment là lee comprend
peut-être que que je suis prêt à l'aider
à les soutenir je ne sais pas te laisser
ces mystérieux là vous rentrez donc dans
une relation amoureuse et dévastatrice
très intenses ils voient beaucoup les
visites quand il boit il devient
agressif il a cette colère qui remonte à
l'enfance
tout à fait c'est une chose qui ne
digère pas je me suis battu toute ma vie
toute ma vie je me suis battu toute ma
vie j'ai espéré ce livre s'appelle un
jour tout ira bien
parce que jacques m'a écrit ce mot qui
figurent dans ce livre on sait l'amour
un jour tout ira bien je te le promets
je t'aime jacques et je me suis accroché
à ses toutes petites phrases un jour
tout ira bien
quand quand il a bu il vous fait peur
oui ça fait pas parce que quelqu'un qui
boit quelqu'un qu'ils sont en prise
d'une drogue
il n'est plus tout à fait de lui même et
il y avait ces espèces de crise qui
pouvait ressembler à rien de très loin
celui où tout d'un coup we have est dédé
il était il était violent mistral qui
cassait tout ça fait peur
ça fait peur il avait une double
personnalité j'arrête et l'alcool y
aurait si c'est pas bien et celle ce
n'était pas bien voyager comme tous les
alcoolo comme tous les drogués il vous
dit je peux m'arrêter quand je veux et
on est dans le déni je crois quand on
est dans cette maladie d' alors ils
traitent toutes les nuits dehors en fait
il disparaît 3 jours 3 nuits sûrement
les scènes de sa résistance vous le
laisser partir vous a gelé sa part tiré
il est difficile de récupérer quelqu'un
moi au départ je suivais avec comme je
vous dis moi j'avais j'avais mon métier
et j'avais mon enfant je ne pouvais pas
comme ça va le suivre sans le chemin de
l'enfer et paraît évident ce levier où
ils allaient quand il partait comme ça
est toujours pas toujours si découvert
plus tard des choses un peu mais bon je
crois que je me cachais je me voyais un
peu la face et vous le voyez arriver le
lendemain en général c'est les flics qui
l'ont mis dans un taxi
oui oui souvent alors au bout d'un
moment ce qui est terrible c'est que il
boit autant quand il est heureux que
quand il est malheureux c'est là qu'on
fait quand claude berri lui propose de
jouer et gaulle un an jean de florette
et manon des sources
il très heureux il boit et quand il
apprend que simone signoret yves montand
ne veulent pas de lui
il boit parce qu'il est malheureux donc
du bois tout le temps c'est récurrent
piscine
n'eussent été installés petit à petit
pour arriver à l'issue que malheureuses
du 28 janvier 2005 alors vous dites que
l'alcool l'amène à manquer de
discernement dans sa carrière qu'un jour
on lui propose trois hommes et un
couffin et il veut pas le faire ou un
mini passer à côté il arrive c'est bien
sûr mais bon c'est pas si grave
alors problème c'est que l'alcool
l'obligé à annuler un certain nombre de
représentations et il faut rembourser
dans ce cas là non remboursés vie c'est
une très dommage pour les tubes ou qui
s'est déplacé qui a réservé longtemps à
l'avancé tarier des toujours ça revient
comme un leitmotiv dans votre bouquin je
m'arrête quand je veux un jour tout ira
bien
c'est sans arrêt au bout d'un moment
vous y croyez plus vous si j'ai toujours
cru parce que quand hamadi d'arrivée
vraiment qu'il ya eu un non
posé sur cette source sûre ce sur sur
les résultats de la vo je me suis dit va
réagir il va réagir comme tout le monde
il va avoir peur de la mort et puis
apparemment non il finit par rencontrer
son père biologique soit aurait pu
effectivement provoquer une
transformation chez lui mais il y avait
un fantasme est sûre ce père mais il y
avait aussi il avait toute latitude pour
partir à sa recherche
donkey ça il a jamais fait la démarche
il avait peur des stades des marges puis
c'est arrivé pendant au début de la
contrebasse alberto 1 et je crois que tu
a tout fait basculer parce que la
rencontre n'a pas été celle qu'il
espérait jeu n'a rien arrangé disant
voilà
non je crois que c'est pierre je crois
que ça fait basculer se trouvant devant
cette réalité qui était assez triste et
s'est senti une seconde fois abandonnée
puisque là cette rencontre n'a pas été
celle qui n'espérait ya pas eu d'amour
ya pas eu de retrouvailles d'amour vous
avez songé à quitter à un moment où vous
vouliez divorcer non oui je les menaçait
c'est moi ou la lco elle mais je
n'aurais jamais fait parce que je suis
incapable de est une maladie on laisse
pas tomber un cancéreux en laisse pas
tomber un alcoolique non plus ils
voulaient pas voir la réalité parce que
quand on lui disait tu vas voir une
cirrhose du foie il disait c'est pas
grave le fois ça repousse un vrai régal
colossal et un soir il fait une
tentative de suicide avec des somnifères
un matin en rentrant ivre mort et vous
de coûts
oui pendant mon sommeil c'est une crise
de nerfs delirium tremens est ce qu il
avait un il était absent et puis c'est
plus souvenu ne se souvenait pas où
c'était c'était impossible
c'était pas lui bonjour vous finissez
par le par le veer est et je n'en
pouvais plus je me sentais mourir moi
même et je lui dise les livecd ici il
aura plus d'alcool à la maison parce que
c'est je peux pas voir cette déchéance
je veux pas être témoin je peux pas
cautionner pas cautionner cette man donc
je lui je lui dis rapide d'alcool à la
maison je sais pas pourquoi j'ai ajouté
sauf du vinaigre et de l'alcool à 90
parce qu'on en a besoin dans une maison
eh ben le choix évidemment au stade de
la maladie je n'étais que perdante donc
respecté ma demande et donc il est parti
s'est installé à l'hôtel aura glané sens
alors là quand vous vous séparez il
passe du sauve moi je vais te pourrir la
vie quoi il a une attitude si quelqu'un
me quittes je je je ne vais pas su plier
je n'allais pas le supplier de rester
bien sûr donc il a senti un désamour
donc ça de la blies était une blessure
narcissique
aussi ils demandent le divorce s'est
vite dans votre bouquin qui vous coupe
les vivres
il ya un truc n'est pas très clair quand
même parce que c'est vous qui gériez ses
finances donc comment il peut juger est
passé sinon ils vous coupe les vivres
vraiment oui maman sa soeur ghislaine
dit que c'est vous qui avez vidé ses
comptes
à écouter prendre en apporte les preuves
j'aurais été très content de vider les
comptes auraient dû faire non j'ai pas
vidé les comptes de messieurs villeray
c'est extraordinaire dit qu'il n'était
pas violent finalement 6 n écoutez je ne
sais pas vic c'est lui la victime
écoutez gestique pas alors tous ces gens
ont un double discours puisque quand il
est décédé
on s'est beaucoup parlé jambon rapport
principe avec ma belle famille et elle
m'a dit cette phrase importante mais tu
sais bien que jacques il n'avait jamais
tort donc ils ont ce faire aussi de sa
mauvaise foi
enfin de son déni qui dénie d'alcool qui
dit kiki passait dans la vie courante
bas mot près les amis vous avez très
mauvaise presse
comment il est je pense pas vraiment
exprès et ça n'a pas d'importance je
crois que j'ai été importante pour
beaucoup de gens de la profession
pendant des années puisque j'ai si
jackie est arrivé là où il est et c'est
parce que j'étais là parce que je le
soutenais parce que je l'aidais aussi
son talent aussi comme bwin en mai
évidemment mais je pense pas que jacques
aurait vécu jusque là je veux dire il ya
d'autres amis communs qui sont qui sont
toujours auprès de moi et qui sont
excessivement choquée qu'ils ont été
excessivement choquée et outrée et
révolté par son attitude mais bon encore
une fois cela ne regarde que nous je
peux vous poser une question un peu bête
vous dites que ça regarde que vous
pourquoi vous écrivez si
alors c'est autre chose parce que moi
j'ai mené un combat contre l'alcool donc
quand il est mort jacques je suis j'ai
été prise par la colère et la révolte
qu'on puisse se donner la mort comme ça
j'ai souffert en silence pendant très
longtemps
pendant des années et c'était au moment
de sa mort qu'il fallait que j'en parle
parce que j'ai pensé aussi à tous ces
gens qui le vivent dans l'ombre à tout
l'entourage qui en souffrent et essayer
de faire passer un message dire à ces
gens qui boivent et qu'ils se détruisent
que l'issue est fatale
gérard vous l'avez connu ou jacques
villeret oui messieurs
oui mais l'effet papy fait de la
résistance en cévennes mais oui c'était
un garçon qui pouvait être double oui
très très très drôle très sympa titre
avec une blessure évidemment au fond
quoi et puis je les ai vus dans son oeil
spectacle n'était pas au mieux de sa
forme quoi c'est un peu peine nord
chaussée lourd quoi tout ça difficile se
passe j'ai pas lu je lis donc je pose
pas la vie est ce que c est ce que c'est
utile oui c'est peut-être utile pour
vous est-ce que c'est utile de parler de
la face cachée en 5 ans quelque part moi
je m'en fous je voyais un acteur
magnifique qui me faisait rire qui me
vais qu'ils soient accueillis par colis
qu'homosexuel hétéro elle est angoissée
que ça
non j'ai on s'en fout que jersey il ya
beaucoup d'acteurs qui méritent pas [ __ ]
et il vaut mieux pas les connaître
moi j'ai connu plein d'acteurs
formidables qu'il fallait mieux pas
connaître le contraire aussi je pense
que c'est pas très important ce qui par
essence non mais c'est pas ça c'est que
je vais vers l'aisne était le plus grand
des poètes et l'année dernière
oui ces jeunes humaine une humanité
assez incertaine donc je sais ce que ça
vous paraît que la chair est très sympa
dans la vie voilà j'aimerais vous poser
les questions sur l'utilité de faire ce
genre de livre banon enfin je pomme
s'est pas produit rare une réaction ça
aurait été un inconnu j'aurais écrit ce
livre il n'aurait pas été publié mais
peut être que si l'argent que vous avez
gagné de l'enfer quoi qu'est-ce qu'on
croyait en faire j'élève ma famille et
celle de ma famille si c'est pour
dénoncer l'alcool peut tout donner une
portée bien sûr mais bien sûr mais je je
je je vais aider à la dent merci
la région
merci d'avoir été avec géo dit
white caps